hmm
get back to work
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
dog
three
then i go back
foreign
here
foreign
surface
i know
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
oh
they saw me
ladies and gentlemen owner of meadow
spring farm
andy ballinger
i just want to welcome you all here
tonight um this is not something that i
ever dreamed we would do on this farm
but it's been quite an experience and i
think it's going to continue to be a
great one
so we just feel very privileged to
be hosting this um still not
100 sure why we were chosen but we're
not
we're not regretting our decision to
host it so we just
hope that you have a lot of fun
[Applause]
and one quick plug for dairy farmers uh
just remember to drink your milk
everyone okay
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen the second lady of
the united states
mrs karen pence
[Music]
[Applause]
lancaster is beautiful
it's beautiful oh it's absolutely
gorgeous so
i have the privilege tonight of
introducing my husband and i'm gonna do
so
by telling you just a little story i
want to take you on a very quick little
journey a synopsis of our political life
so when we started dating mike said to
me
you know someday i just want you to know
i want to represent my hometown
in the united states congress
and after we got married we felt the
call to run
in 1988 and we ran
on the theme of faith
family and freedom
and we lost
so we decided in 1990
we're gonna run again and mike ran on
the theme
faith family
and freedom
and i'm sorry to say we lost again
and so we decided to build our dream
home
mike started a radio show i started a
watercolor business
god blessed us with three beautiful
children
and life was going just great
and then we felt called to run again in
the year 2000
and again we ran on the theme
faith family and
freedom and god blessed us
with a victory that year
and over the next over the next 12 years
mike pence rose to a leadership role in
the congress he ended up being
the third highest member of the house of
representatives
and during that time we had a small home
in indiana
and mike likes to stay in a smaller home
in washington
and we raised our children
during those 12 years in congress
and my kids never felt
like they were second fiddle to his
political career
they never did i mean he would leave the
hill
he'd come to a lacrosse game and he'd go
back he'd leave the hill he'd come to a
little poetry show and he'd go back
he'd come to a violin recital and he
would go back
and during those 12 years
unless there was a flight delay every
sunday
we worshiped together as a family
and during those years
during those years he fought for freedom
so even during the 12 years in congress
the theme that ran through our home and
his career
and our lives was faith family and
freedom
and then we felt called to go home to
indiana
and to run for governor and again
we ran on the theme faith
family and freedom and we were preparing
to run for our second term
as governor and first lady of indiana
when lo and behold somebody called
and said mike will you be my running
mate
actually actually he didn't say it that
way he said mike
it's gonna be great
he did and mike said well if there's a
question there
the answer is yes
but president donald trump has shown
all of us over the past four years
that he is fighting for our faith
our families and our freedom we need
four more years
yes and so
we need four more years of president
donald trump
and we need four more years of vice
president
mike pence
[Music]
[Music]
is
maybe we can see
[Music]
well hello pennsylvania
it is great to be here at the battle
spring farm
and didn't see something could you join
me in thanking a marine
corps mom who loves our military
families traveling the country
supporting our soldiers
and a great second lady of the united
states of america karen pence
[Music]
my friend congressman lloyd smucker how
great is he
[Music]
[Applause]
been a tremendous ally of our
administration taking the strong stands
lord we appreciate you so much
and uh how about a big round of applause
for the whole bollinger family for
opening up this spectacular
thank you so much
but i got to tell you it's good to be
with all of you tonight
just about two hours and seven minutes
to go
it's on pennsylvania
it's going to be a great night
i can tell you i left the president
earlier today in the oval office
and he's ready
we're ready and tonight we start the
steady
march to 35 days when we'll reelect
president donald trump for four more
[Music]
years
i mean really truly it's great to have
you all come out tonight
the president's off in cleveland nine
o'clock eastern
you all can check it out right here
but i was talking the other day and i
said well you know there's some people
invited me to go to pennsylvania
and he looked at me and he said you go
to pennsylvania i'll handle ohio
and i know he will
i promise you everybody come nine
o'clock eastern president donald trump
is going to take our case
to the american people and he's going to
take the fight straight to joe biden
but i know you all are here for the same
reason i'm here
it's not just to watch a debate it's
because you all know that it's not even
just for that
[Applause]
but it's because pennsylvania and
america need
four more years of president donald
trump
in the white house
and the road to victory goes straight
through
pennsylvania don't doubt it
you know four years ago a movement was
born
a movement of everyday americans from
every walk of life
here in pennsylvania you believed we
could be strong again
you believe we could be prosperous again
pennsylvania said yes to president
donald trump in 2016
and i know come november 3rd
pennsylvania is going to say yes to four
more years
of president donald trump
think how far we've come
and four years ago we inherited a
military that had been hollowed out by
devastating budget cuts
an economy that under joe biden in the
last administration was going through
the slowest
economic recovery since the great
depression
terrorism was on the rise around the
world
and we witnessed a steady assault
on our most cherished values but in
three short years
under the leadership of president donald
trump
with the strong support of leaders from
congress like lloyd schmucker
we rebuild our military we've restored
the arsenal democracy
and we're finally giving our soldiers
sailors airmen marines and coast guard
the resources and the support that you
deserve to accomplish your mission
and come home safe
and i got to tell you i know karen told
you the story of uh that season in our
life when those three little kids came
along
i got to tell you i couldn't be more
proud that
our oldest is a captain in the united
states marine corps and our daughter
just married a lieutenant
in the united states navy
[Applause]
and that's why i i couldn't be more
proud as a vice president
and a dad to serve alongside a president
who cares
so deeply about the men and women of our
armed forces
and their families
and it hasn't been just those who wear
the uniform it's been those who've worn
the uniform in the united states
i know there's probably more than a few
men and women in the room that are
that served in our armed forces if you
can can you just raise your hand in the
air and give us a chance to say thank
you one more time
thank you for your service
let's hear it for these veterans
everybody come on
[Applause]
it's a debt we can never fully repay but
on behalf of all the people that just
stood and cheered let me say to all the
veterans who are here
thank you for your service to the united
states of america
and in those first three years president
donald trump stood with our veterans
like no president in my lifetime
when joe biden was vice president of the
united states you remember
the years of scandals at the va
literally veterans were dying
waiting to receive care at our va
hospitals
and in our first year in office
president donald trump
signed a reform bill that created all
new accountability at the va we have
fired thousands
of va workers that weren't giving our
veterans what they need
and now veterans choice is now available
to every veteran in america
so we stood with our troops we've stood
with our veterans and under this
president
we've stood with working men and women
like never before president donald trump
rolled up his sleeves in those first
three years and
i just got to keep mentioning your
congressman with the strong support of
congressman lloyd smucker we cut taxes
across the board
we rolled back regulations at an
unprecedented
level we fought for free and fair
trade and we unleashed american energy
the fracking revolution is creating
tens of thousands of jobs across america
and today today while joe biden and his
running mate
on the record repeatedly about
abolishing
fossil fuels joe biden said last year he
looked a young woman in the eye and he
said
he said i guarantee i guarantee
we'll abolish fossil fuels now he says
he's not going to ban fracking but i'll
tell you something
we just need to listen to him the first
four times
when he said he was but i promise you
this
with four more years of president donald
trump in the white house we're going to
continue to achieve
american energy independence and the
best is yet to come
for pennsylvania and america
i mean where joe biden literally in the
middle of a global pandemic joe biden
wants to raise taxes by four trillion
dollars
this president cut taxes across the
board laid a foundation
that now as we beginning to open up
pennsylvania again
open up america again
we're seeing the american economy come
roaring back
in fact in our first three years alone
businesses large and small created seven
million good paying jobs and 208 000
jobs
right here in pennsylvania the truth is
we also stood with america's farmers
all along the way i mean i got to tell
[Applause]
you
under under joe biden it was economic
surrender
countries around the world under
president donald trump whether it came
to china or our trading partners in the
north and south
he made it clear the era of economic
surrender
is over he stood strong for american
farmers he stood strong
for american workers
[Applause]
when china started to retaliate against
american farmers president trump just
he just used some of what we were
collecting in tariffs on china
and made it available to american
farmers over 13 billion dollars to
support american agriculture
yeah we're making farming great again i
love the hand
[Music]
and one of the ways we did that is when
we cut taxes in those first three years
we eliminated the death tax for nearly
every family farm in america
[Applause]
i mean the truth is in our first three
years the results speak for themselves
we rebuilt our military we created and
revived
a booming economy the strongest economy
in the world
we launched an energy renaissance where
today america is a net
exporter of energy for the first time in
70 years
and all along the way all along the way
president donald trump has stood for the
rule
of law he kept his word to the people of
this great state
and we've seen more than 200 principled
conservatives
appointed to our federal courts at every
level including justice neil gorsuch
and justice brett kavanaugh
[Applause]
and i can tell you i've met a lot of
these great judges
i've met a lot of them and they're all
men and women
who will uphold all the god-given
liberties enshrined in our constitution
like the freedom of speech the freedom
of religion
and the second amendment right to keep
and bear arms
and you all heard just recently we we
marked the passing of a
of a true public servant
ruth bader ginsburg served for decades
on the supreme court and we honor her
service in her life
but president donald trump did his duty
under article 2 of the constitution that
stipulates that the president
shall appoint judges to the supreme
court
and last saturday night
[Applause]
the president announced his decision to
appoint a woman of great character with
an incredible family
a principled conservative who reveres
the constitution
of the united states he named the next
great justice of the supreme court
amy coney barrett
i'll tell you what when she was
confirmed to the court of appeals just a
few short years ago one of the
democrats on the judiciary committee
lamented the fact that her
her faith which she called her dogma
lived loudly in her yes well i got the
same dogma
and i'm going to tell you i had a chance
to walk her up the steps of the senate
today to get her started in the process
we got a hearing coming up right around
the corner in just a few short weeks
with your support the support of all of
our republican colleagues
every single one of them we can get i
promise you
judge amy coney barrett is going to
become justice
amy coney barrett we're going to fill
that seat oh we're gonna fail
so we stood for the rule of law through
judicial appointments
stood up for all the ideals that you
cherish in great places like lancaster
and
places like the small town i grew up in
and
every step of the way president
donald trump has stood with the men and
women who serve on the thin blue line of
law enforcement
and all our first responders and we
always will
you know i got to tell you my uncle was
a police officer in chicago illinois for
25 years and my cousin was married
to a firefighter for a quarter of a
century in the same city
but we've got we got first responders in
our
in our extended family i don't know what
it's like to put on that uniform but i
know the courage
that it takes for them to do it and i
admire it every day
that's why the president was pleased to
announce today that the philadelphia
firefighters and paramedics union local
22
of the international association of
firefighters endorsed president donald
trump
for re-election it means a lot
it means a lot
[Applause]
we're grateful for the support of
firefighters and all our first
responders
you know president trump and i know what
you all know out this way
men and women who serve in law
enforcement are some of the best people
in this country
and they deserve the respect of every
american
every single day
now like all of you the president and i
will always respect the right of
americans to peaceful protest it's
enshrined in the constitution
but rioting and looting is not peaceful
protest
burning businesses is not free speech
harming and threatening civilians and
law enforcement officers will not be
tolerated
and those who do these things will be
prosecuted
to the fullest extent of the law
you know for months all joe biden ever
talked about was peaceful protesters
remember all summer long literally while
the american people were watching
watching businesses and streets in our
major cities literally burn
i made a trip up to minneapolis not long
ago
and we connected with a wonderful woman
named flora westbrook floor is a
great african-american business woman
she ran a salon
that she started about 30 years ago but
she told me through a veil of tears
the days that followed the killing of
george floyd how she literally watched
the rioters and looters
come closer and closer to her business
until that friday night when they burned
her out
but i told flora we're going to stand
with her we're going to stay with her
and we're going to rebuild
not only her business but all of our
cities and we're going to end this
violence
once and for all and we're going to have
law and order for every american
of every race and creed and color
so help us god
[Applause]
i mean the truth is joe biden and his
running mate would double down on the
policies that have literally led to
violence in america cities
when you undermine support for law
enforcement
when you cheer as his running mate did
los angeles decision to cut 150 million
dollars out of the police budget
you embolden the worst elements of the
community
i mean literally joe biden says that
america is in his words
systemically racist he also says that
law enforcement has a quote
implicit bias against minorities
when joe biden was asked whether he
would cut funding for law enforcement he
replied quote
yes absolutely
let me make you a promise lancaster
under president donald trump
we're not going to defund the police not
now
now you all know what the president and
i know we don't have to choose between
supporting law enforcement
and supporting all of the families that
live in our major cities
we have done both for the last three and
a half years
and we're going to support law
enforcement and support our
african-american
and minority families for four more
years in the white house
[Applause]
so we made incredible progress in those
first three years rebuild our military
revived our economy
strengthened the foundation under the
rule of law
redoubled our commitment to law and
order
and then the coronavirus struck from
china
but i'm here to tell you having led the
task force over the last eight months
that
when president donald trump made the
decision
to suspend all travel from china
before the end of january before the
first case
of community transmission he saved
countless
american lives
[Applause]
no other american president had ever
suspended travel from another nation
president donald trump took that action
he stood up the white house coronavirus
task force
and bought us an invaluable amount of
time to launch the greatest national
mobilization since world war ii
joe biden when the president suspended
travel from china joe biden said it was
hysterical xenophobic
and was fear-mongering but i can tell
you what it was
it was leadership that put the health of
america first
and with the time that we bought we
reinvented testing we just cleared 100
million tests done last week more than
any other nation in the world by far
we develop and and help manufacture
literally
billions of personal protective
equipment no american who required an
icu bed was ever denied an icu bed
no american who required a ventilator
was ever denied
a ventilator we work hard with private
industry
to make sure every american family got
the health care that any one of us would
want
a loved one to have we've developed
medicines that have literally been
saving lives every day and we
are on track to have the first
coronavirus vaccine before the end of
this year
and have tens of millions of doses
to administer so we're slowing the
spread
for protecting the vulnerable we're
saving lives
and under the president's leadership
we're opening up america again
on that foundation the president board
literally in the last
four months more than 10 and a half
million americans have already gone back
to work
i mean there are more americans that
have gone back to work
in the last four months than got a job
in the eight years that joe biden was
vice president
at the height of the pandemic we lost 22
million
jobs but because of the foundation the
president poured
and because of the unprecedented support
congressman lloyd smucker and members of
congress frankly in both parties
relief for families relief for
businesses we've added 10.6 million
jobs back including 580
000 jobs back right here in pennsylvania
[Applause]
we're opening up america again and we're
opening up
america's schools
[Applause]
yesterday because of the innovation that
the president initiated six months ago
with our major research companies
we announced in the rose garden and
we're going to be distributing 100
million point of care rapid tests
to all the states across the country so
they can distribute them
to school nurses and school systems so
our kids
can get back in the classroom and our
kids can stay
back in school safely
[Applause]
so we've gone through a time of testing
you've seen the president's leadership
writ large
and in those first three years you saw
this president deliver on all the
promises that he made to people in
pennsylvania
but we're coming to a time for choosing
which is what that debate is all about
tonight
and i literally can't wait
i can't wait somebody said to me
uh how long has the president been
preparing for the debate
i said all his life
and he's going to lay out not only what
we've done but he's going to lay out the
choice
he's going to take the fight straight to
joe biden i mean look
think about the choice that we face here
in the middle of a of a global pandemic
joe biden wants to raise taxes by four
trillion dollars
president trump and i we're gonna keep
cutting taxes for four more years and
bring this economy
all the way back and then some
joe biden i know the president will
bring this up tonight joe biden wants to
bury our economy under an avalanche of
red tape beginning with the green new
deal
[Music]
you know the only thing green about the
green new deal is how much green it's
going to cost all of us if they ever
pass any of it into law
you know the truth of the matter is that
for all that we did in those 45 days to
slow the spread
remember the sacrifices that we made
where we shut down literally large parts
of our economy we asked businesses and
families to make great sacrifices to put
the health of america first
did you know that in those 45 days we
still didn't come
close to reaching the emission
reductions in the green new deal
i mean their environmental agenda would
destroy
american jobs we're going to keep
cutting
regulation unleashing energy and we're
going to create
millions of american jobs in four more
years
and as i said before where joe biden
joe biden was a cheerleader for china
for all of the modern owners you know
when we took office
literally half of our international
trade deficit was with china
we were losing 500 billion dollars a
year
to communist china when president donald
trump put him on
on notice he said those those things are
over
we stood up to china we imposed tariffs
to level
the playing field for american workers
and joe biden is actually talking about
repealing all the tariffs
that are level in the playing field but
i promise you
with four more years in the white house
we're going to stand
strong against china until they open
their markets respect private property
and level the playing field for american
jobs and american farmers
and closer to home you know joe biden
was there when they passed nafta into
law
i tell people across the heartland the
impact that nafta had
did you know that 60 000 american
factories closed
in the years from nafta to the present
day
remember the last administration the
last president said about four years ago
right now he's asked about manufacturing
jobs they'd lost 200 000
manufacturing jobs and he said they were
never going to come back
he said what magic wand do you have
well we didn't need a magic wand we just
needed president donald trump in the
white house
500 000 manufacturing jobs created
in our first three years
and with the new trade deal that got rid
of nafta the united states mexico canada
agreement it's actually expected to
increase exports by tens of billions of
dollars create tens of thousands of jobs
and
standing here on this wonderful farm i'm
proud to report
under the usmca we're we're projected to
increase
dairy exports by more than 300 million
dollars
a year that's what winning
looks like pennsylvania that's the
leadership of president donald trump
so it's been about it's been about
security and prosperity
but it's also been about our most
cherished values
and i hope that comes up tonight
i mean truthfully when joe biden was
vice president of the united states they
literally hauled
the little sisters of the poor into
federal court
to force them to compromise their faith
to comply with the strictures and
mandates of obamacare
president donald trump when we came into
office
we ended the assault on the little
sisters of the poor
and the supreme court of the united
states just made it permanent
[Applause]
under president donald trump we are
going to stand
for the religious freedom of every
american
of every faith every single day
and maybe most important of all to our
little family
and so many of yours at a time when joe
biden
supports late term abortion and using
taxpayer dollars
to pay for abortion all the way up to
the moment of birth
i couldn't be more proud to serve as
vice president to a president
who stands without apology for the
sanctity of human life
president donald trump is the most
pro-life president
in american history
i mean when you look at their agenda
it's clear joe biden would be nothing
more than a trojan horse for the radical
left
it's overtaken the democratic party
now joe biden said at their convention i
don't know did you watch some of their
convention
i didn't watch much of it either
was like a it was like a zoom hr meeting
or something
but you know at their convention joe
biden said democracy is on the ballot
we might hear him say something like
that in the debate tonight
i'll tell you what president trump and i
know is that
the economy is on the ballot law and
order
are on the ballot
but you know we also know there are
things uh more foundational and more
fundamental to our country than that
you know when i think of this election
when i think of those values that my
wife
shared with you have always
characterized our calling
and define the leadership of your
present
commitment to the timeless american
ideals of faith and family
and freedom i'm absolutely convinced
that
come election day it's not going to be
uh whether
america is more conservative or more
liberal
whether we're more republican or more
democrat more red or more blue i
i think the choice in this election
gonna come down to whether america
remains america
so if you believe
in faith and family and freedom and
patriotism we got to decide right here
and right now that joe biden will never
be president of the united states
we're going to re-elect president donald
trump
for four more years
[Applause]
just got to decide pennsylvania
[Applause]
you did it before i know you're going to
do it again
so bring all your enthusiasm all right
and after you see this debate tonight
you'll forget i was even here
because he's going to bring it
he's going to bring it but i want you to
take the message that you've heard the
president
talk about go talk to your neighbors and
friends
if you believe as i do what's at stake
in this election
i just need you to do what you did
before four years ago
i mean tell them all that we
accomplished in those first three years
together tell
them what this president's leadership
has accomplished through this
challenging time
in the life of our nation and made it
possible for the great american comeback
that's underway
and tell them tell them four more years
means more jobs
tell them four more years means more
judges
four more years means more support for
our troops
[Applause]
four more years means more support for
law enforcement
and all of our first responders
and tell them tell them i ran into mike
out on the farm and he said it's going
to take at least
four more years to drain that swamp
will you go tell it
because i'm absolutely convinced i'm
absolutely convinced on
this big debate night that what happened
in 2016
is happening again all across this
country the people
people aren't listening to the pundits
and the
so-called elites in washington dc
we're just talking to their neighbors
and friends and i got to tell you i'll
never forget karen and i will never
forget that election night
we were standing right next to the
president you can go online and look it
up these young people will help you find
it there's a they've
got a good picture we're there at the
campaign headquarters weren't we dear in
new york city
and every time every time an estate came
in
he was standing next to me he's a little
bit taller than me he would turn to me
and he'd just tap me on the shoulder and
say look at that
said look at that he said indiana came
in great
you see hank georgia came in good right
south carolina good but i gotta tell you
when pennsylvania came through i thought
he was gonna knock me
down
so you got to do it again pennsylvania
[Applause]
you did it before and you can do it
again
you just got to have faith he's got to
have faith
i think what happened in 2016 is the
american people just
we had faith in one another we had faith
in our highest ideals
we had faith that when you when you
lifted up
freedom the american people would rally
to your cause
so when you talk to your neighbors and
friends have faith because i
i can honestly tell you that a long
study of american history shows that
in this state where literally our
freedom was
minted in that great constitution
1787. every time the american people
have been given a clear choice between
more freedom
and less freedom they choose more
freedom every single time
so have faith when you talk to your
neighbors and friends
and i'd encourage you also to have that
other kind of faith if you're inclined
to
bow the head and bend the knee over the
next 35 some odd days
i encourage you to do got it
there's a verse in the old book i
especially like says the horse is made
ready for the day of battle
but victory comes from the lord so you
pray
you pray for a victory not just
not just for our team not just for our
great supporters around the country but
i mean
let's go out there and win a victory for
america come november 3rd
and a victory for everything that has
always made
america great and will make america
great again
let's go win it
and i'm absolutely convinced if all of
us will do all that we need to do
between now november 3rd
i promise you the president and i are
going to be in this fight
you'll see it tonight
and karen and i are going to head to
salt lake city next week and do our
level best as
[Applause]
but well single day i promise you
served alongside him shoulder to
shoulder
when the cameras are off when nobody's
looking i can promise you
president donald trump has never stopped
fighting for you now it's your turn to
fight for him
so let's bring it pennsylvania
i'm absolutely convinced that with your
strong support with your strong voice to
your neighbors and friends
in every day over the next 35 days
congressman lloyd smucker
back in a republican majority in the
united states house of representatives
with strong conservative leaders elected
and re-elected
all across this state in this nation
with four more years of president donald
trump
in the white house and with god's help
we're going to make pennsylvania more
prosperous than you could possibly
imagine
we're going to make all of pennsylvania
and america safer
than ever before and with your strong
support i know
in my heart we're going to make america
great again
again thank you very much
god bless you god bless america
[Music]
new york city
[Music]
is
[Music]
dreams
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
you